This is how the world works.
The sun shines, the grass grows.
Kobe Bryant arrives to practice at three.
The other three.
Chickens bock, bock, bock.
Broccoli can fight cancer.
Rice provides energy.
Kobe eats rice, broccoli, chicken...
...and the world turns.
Earthquakes shake.
Bakers bake.
Kobe Bryant shakes and bakes defenders.
Philosophers ponder existence.
Scholars read.
Kobe Bryant takes everyone to school.
Rain falls, waterfalls dump water.
Kobe owns the bucket.
That bucket.
Snakes are light, low and fast.
Kobe's shoes are like snakes.
Bees sting when threatened.
Kobe Bryant is never threatened.
Best is ahead of better.
The basket is ahead of the ball.
Kobe is light-years ahead of them all.
This is the way it was,...
...this is the way it is,...
...this is the way it will be.